ciao da ex grosseto mi chiamo luca
armeni e se lonate cresce del maremma
[Musica]
sono qui oggi prepararti intelligenze
artificiali delle opportunità e dei
rischi relativi a questa nuova
rivoluzione mi vorrei innanzitutto
invitare a riflettere su due domande
apparentemente distaccate ma il cui in
esso diverrà sempre più importante nel
nostro futuro
la prima vorresti vivere in una società
dove determinate scelte
al riguardo della vostra educazione
carriera e salute vengano prese in modo
automatizzato quali sarebbero le
opportunità e i pericoli della società
volta in piena fede all'ottimizzazione
ma soprattutto vi invita a riflettere su
questa seconda domanda com'è possibile
conoscere com'è possibile
in altre parole acquisire e rielaborare
per informazioni non solo dal punto di
vista psicologico ma anche dal punto di
vista linguistico
partiamo da qui nell'ora bola che
attesti e rapido ne ricava 3 peculiarità
non nasconde non parla ma dagli indizi
c'è una parola latina il cui etimo si
compone dal verbo fiero che significa
portare e se accostata al prefisso in
diviene portare in portare attraverso
tale mostra inferenza è il termine che
designa la selezione ed acquisizione che
ho informazioni a partire da dati indizi
aristotele ne aveva definite free tv
l'induzione dove la regola e postulata a
partire da un risultato ed un caso
particolare la deduzione dove un
risultato è un postulato a parte una
regola in un caso
ed infine la produzione dove è un caso
ad essere postulato in altre parole dove
si formano un ipotesi charles pierce uno
dei massimi filosofi americani
contemporanei nonché uno dei padri
fondatori della semiotica la disciplina
che studia i semi di soia significati
aveva individuato proprio nel inferenza
additiva la possibilità di un altro
interpretativo in quanto il primissimo
passo della signora l'asse miosi è
l'atto di condizione del senso ed inizia
infatti quando e selezioniamo formiamo e
da parliamo da te ipotesi che non
potevano essere spiegate seguendo delle
regole strette fossero di natura logica
o analogica sono un dottorando
intelligenza artificiale o meglio in ex
teleco e intelligenza
ufficiale esplicabile ma direte voi che
cos'è l'intelligenza artificiale
beh potremmo descriverla come quella di
vita di alcune macchine di alcuni
software di potere imparare ma imparare
non proprio nell'accensione a alla
cognizione umana ecco imparare a partire
da dei dati che vengono forniti e da
questi dati sono estratte correlazioni
che permettono di classificare
rappresentare e il prevedere determinate
le tendenze una rivoluzione in atto e si
basa sui dati che continuamente
produciamo mai prima nella storia umana
abbiamo avuto la possibilità di
costruire sistemi che massimizzano
rendimenti logistici consigliano e
anticipa la nostra bertone di consumo
diagnosticano patologie meglio dei
nostri trattori o persino durano
nuovamente la parola possibilità di
muoversi a chi era affetto da disabilità
faccio parte di un progetto della
commissione europea volto a formare
ricercatori e metodologie per spiegare
come l'intelligenza artificiale elabori
articoli questi decisioni in quanto oggi
queste macchine questi numeri sono
talvolte difficilmente interpretabili
bensì dagli addetti ai lavori e con
l'intero sempre più massicce tecnologie
di intelligenza artificiale le
opportunità ma anche rizzi qui questa
riserva stanno crescendo in modo
esponenziale
per questa ragione nel 2019 dell'unione
europea si è data delle linee guida
per sviluppare modelli di ira che siano
etici per meglio dire che non arrechino
danno ai cittadini utilizzandone i dati
in modo sicuro imparziale e trasparente
questa politica si inserisce nella corsa
globale a via e trova come altri grandi
attori comprimari appunto gli stati
uniti e la cina
parlando di cina parlando di
accessibilità e intelligenza artificiale
in alcune province della cina è in atto
un esperimento ormai da anni da parte
del governo che si chiami fine essere
espansa tutta la nazione entro la fine
del 2020 è un piano per lo sviluppo di
un sistema di ferito sociale questo
credito riflette il comportamento e il
background socio economico di ogni
singolo cittadino e viene elaborato
attraverso tecnologie di io ad esempio
se il cittadino non attraversa la strada
sulle strisce o non è stata pagamento di
tasse dei software riconosceranno lamis
condotta e dunque né abbasseranno il
credito di rispettino vita rendendo
quindi per lui difficile accedere a
prestiti opportunità innovative a
lavorative e pagando maggiormente alcuni
servizi
il fatto davvero interessante è però che
l'architettura il software via che
decide come ponderare questi crediti
oltre che essere presubilmente davvero
complesso non è accessibile non può
essere di pubblico dominio
quindi non possiamo valutare se sia
imparziale se possa commettere degli
errori decisionali e se sia manipolabili
internamente gli stati uniti
se la cavano decisamente meglio in fatto
di trasparenza con grandi agent
ecologica quali google facebook amazon
molte altre che si stanno dando delle
linee guida sul piano etico ma talvolta
è ribaltata alle cronache come di queste
tecnologie in uso alle forze di polizia
o compagnie private
se si è rivelato un discriminatorio
verso certi campioni etnici verso certi
identità dicembre
questo errore di valutazione tra il nome
di by us è letteralmente tradotti
significano pregiudizi e possono essere
dovuti al naqoura tezza di alcuni
parenti della macchina o più spesso alla
qualità dei dati forniti direte voi qui
casca l'asino
se c'è un detto che recita le macchine
provino alla macchina un solo difetto
tra esattamente ciò che gli viene
richiesto
i modelli di chi sa non hanno infatti
una concezione di cosa si ha diritto
legale cosa sia l'etica che cosa sia la
sfera psicologica o cosa sia di per sé
un essere umano giulia uno dei padrini
intelligenze artificiali moderna nonché
tra i massimi esperti di reti neurali
quelle architetture che soggiacciono a
moltissimi modelli di apprendimento
automatico ha più volte insistito nel
corso della sua carriera su come
l'intelligenza artificiale ad oggi non
sia reale intelligenza li ha non è
intelligente perché perché non possiede
la verità di ragionare sui rapporti
causa effetto il mondo produttivo ossia
creando delle ipotesi che giustificano
casualmente e determinate correlazioni
presenti a posteriori nei dati forniti
in parole povere le macchine non possono
ragionare come la mente umana né
tantomeno imparare come i bambini
diversi studiosi da diversi ambiti
umanistici psicologici informatici si
stanno ora concentrando insieme la
creazione di modelli di regia è di
artifici al genero le tutele di
intelligenze artificiali generali che
possano competere se non sorpassare nel
prossimo futuro le nostre abilità
cognitive e mnemoniche non è un
obiettivo raggiungibile
le termine perché per emulare la mente
umana serviranno modelli capaci di
integrare un po composizionale domini
differenti tra i lanci netto visual e la
coordinazione motoria la fondamenti tlc
fisica geometriche per le leggi coincide
quale ad esempio la percezione
d'attenzione erano scesi poli che i
freni semantici arrivando persino a
dover includere delle delle fondamenti
di psicologici quale per esempio la
empatia e la mentalizzazione la capacità
di capire gli stati mentali e non
tensione altrui ma anche quando ora un
domani ottenessimo delle macchine capaci
di ragionare come noi insieme a noi
davvero ne avremo bisogno non correremo
rischi ancora più grandi di quelli che
ad oggi fronteggiamo in tanti che
talvolta si dimostra inaccurati i
modelli che non possiamo interpretare o
ancora peggio possono essere impiegati
senza il nostro consenso al fine di in
qualche modo ecco manipolare le nostre
scelte di consumo a sorvegliarci la
faccenda è senz'altro insidiosa è
tutt'altro che semplice specialmente
perché è stato recentemente definito un
nuovo tipo di bayern e questo byas
questo giudizio non appartiene alle
macchine appartenendo l'auto ma the show
sbaglia si designa infatti la tendenza
che abbiamo a considerare che
attendibili le informazioni fornite da
una macchina rispetto a quelle di un
essere umano
c'è un altro motto che mi stata
propriamente al cuore è un motto latino
rappresenta anche la royal society però
il suo site is è la più importante
accademia di chance inglese è molto
recita in vrba
parafrasando potremmo tradurlo con non
prendere mai la parola di nessuno per
garante
sì sempre scettico conduce steri in modo
in cui ricorda come la finalità di ogni
investigazione in filosofica non sia
quella di conoscere cosa sia da virtù ma
bensì cosa voglia dire divenire buoni
altrimenti ogni investimento sarebbe di
per sè inutile quindi licenza
artificiale avrà un impatto sempre
maggiore nelle nostre vite e tutti noi
sia come nazioni come industria ma
soprattutto come singoli cittadini
siamo oggi chiamati a continuamente
ripensare il nostro apporto con essa
l'intelligenza artificiale ci offrirà
opportunità inedite ma a patto che non
la si consideri della ex machina sempre
vero quanto più uno strumento
necessariamente democratico accessibile
conoscibile e dunque falsificabili
sottoposto continuamente la nostra
convalida concludo con una politica di
umberto eco il computer non è una
macchina intelligente caeli delle
persone ma anzi era una macchina stupida
che funziona solo nelle mani delle
persone intelligenti